what is the difference between $500
copyrighting and
$5,000 copyrighting well spoiler alert
it has nothing to do with the
copywriting and in this video I'm going
to tell you how I went from charging a
couple hundred for my copywriting to
multiple thousands of dollars plus
commission for my copywriting but before
we dive into the video I have a gift for
you I want to give you copyrighting
Catalyst it's 63 cash Cal copyrighting
tips for you to read in 90 seconds or
less each tip so that way you can get a
ton of copyrighting free value to help
you start charging more for your copy
today it's free all you got to do is hit
the link in the description below put in
your email and tell me where to send it
so that way I can get it over to you
today I appreciate it I hope that's
really really helpful for you now let's
dive right into the video here's the
real difference between $500
copyrighting and $5,000
copyrighting here on my wrist I have a
Seiko watch and this watch cost me about
almost $1,000 it's not the most
expensive watch in the world it's also
not the cheapest watch in the world but
a watch that I'm about to buy is a Rolex
date just which cost about
$10,000 so what's the difference between
my $1,000 watch and a $110,000 Rolex
well they both do the same thing right
they tell time they're both pretty high
quality pieces right it would be hard to
tell tell the difference if I took the
names off of both of them so what is the
difference well in that case scenario
you're probably saying well one of them
is a seyo and the other one's a Rolex
exactly the difference is the status of
the seyo versus the Rolex when you wear
a Rolex you have more status and so a
Rolex is able to demand more money
because of its status status has a price
tag and as a copywriter I'm going to
help you you get that price tag of
status by increasing your status now
this is assuming that you're actually a
pretty good copywriter right like you
can go get your clients some good
results but you still feel like you're
not able to charge enough well status is
the difference between why you're
getting your clients great results but
you can't charge enough but people like
Dan Kennedy and John Carlton Daniel
thrussell Ben settle Gary pegan these
guys can charge thousands of dollars for
their copyrighting before even writing a
single word it all boils down to their
status and I'm about to give you five
super simple tips to help you increase
your status as a copywriter today so you
could start charging more tomorrow
starting with status tip number one
increase your brand aesthetic your brand
aesthetic are the little interactions
that you make with either your customers
or your clients so like if you're
writing for yourself and your own
personal brand you would have customers
but if you're writing for clients you
would have clients either way your brand
aesthetic matters things like your
profile picture the head shot that you
put in there your banners uh the look of
the proposals that you send the
portfolio that you send your website the
domain that you send it from all of
those things add up to your brand
perception how people perceive you when
they interact with you so I'm going to
show you how to juice up those things
right now like for your profile picture
on LinkedIn on Twitter on your Gmail
when you send emails I personally hired
a professional photographer to take
professional studio head shot of me this
cost me a couple hundred bucks and I've
been using those pictures for years and
I use them everywhere I use them in my
portfolio on Twitter on LinkedIn
Instagram Gmail all that stuff so a
couple hundred bucks well spent if you
can't spend a couple hundred bucks doing
this I would highly recommend uh getting
a really nice iPhone Google pixel
whatever it is putting it on portrait
mode taking an excellent portrait in
great lighting natural lighting outside
would be the best and then doing a a
decent job editing this will take you 10
15 minutes to YouTube on how to edit a
nice Studio style photo or a nice photo
outside but it will increase your status
and make you look like a professional
because professionals get paid a couple
of other tips to help you is I would
consider getting a nice website template
on Squarespace or card and that way you
can get Prof professional designs
without having to have a professional
designer and you can also use templates
from canva for your banner so your
LinkedIn Banner your Twitter Banner
YouTube Banner you can go into canva
type in Twitter Banner find all their
templates choose a template maybe switch
out the words and Bam you now have a
really highly professional design
template so your photos look good your
banners look good your website looks
good you can also use canva for your
proposals so when you send proposals
over to clients it's this beautiful
proposal that you send all those little
touch points make it seem like you're
chucking a truck or if you're a
professional Business and Professional
businesses get paid my last tip here on
Aesthetics is getting a custom domain
when I send an email I send it from
Allen dru.com that's my name that's a
professional domain it's custom you
could go to godaddy.com buy a domain
preferably your name and use that for
your website and your email it's
significantly more professional than
coming from at gmail.com yahoo.com I
mean it costs you 10 bucks and it really
does legitimize you as a business status
tip number two is increase your brand
Association brand Association are things
like who have you worked with before I
could say certain things like I've
worked with Brands like AMX TMG guitar
Co Proctor and Gamble CrossFit hope well
farms and a whole bunch of other brands
now I know what you're thinking is Allan
I haven't worked with any bigname Brands
like that that's okay this is where free
work comes into play because when you do
free work it's important just to get a
list of Brands even if they don't know
who they are yes high-profile brands are
better if you could say names like MX
and Proctor and Gamble but even just
having a list of five to 10 companies
organizations or whatever that you've
worked with is still good brand
Association so if you go work with some
local coffee shops you could say 9 East
coffee worked with these guys or
whatever like just getting some brand
Association will automatically increase
your status because those people don't
know who they are and they could just
say wow they've worked with a lot of
cool companies and that work signifies
experience that experience means you can
charge more for what you do status tip
number three is increase your
testimonials there are two types of
testimonials there's lowprofile
testimonials and there's high-profile
testimonials lowprofile testimonial
means the people that you are selling to
likely don't know who those people are
so if you go to my website Allen dru.com
you'll scroll and you'll see there's a
bunch of testimonials well a lot of them
are low profile and some of them are
high-profile I tend to separate those
out the low profile ones you really want
to go for quantity you want to get as
many as possible I've had over 200
people review my daily email newsletter
so when you scroll on it you'll see whoa
that's a lot of people reviewing it not
all of them are high-profile though I've
got about 30 high-profile people on my
list people you would know like Daniel
throssel Eddie Quan Kieran Drew Tom
Benny the difference between those is
when I write to copywriters and they see
some of those big high-profile names on
my list that is a testimonial that means
a lot more so the more you could get
high-profile testimonials even if it's
just a few those increase your status
like crazy because what you're doing is
you're borrowing Authority from somebody
else and they're basically co-signing
what you do whether it's email copy or
metac copy I use a service like s.o to
collect all my testimonials and I even
have a request in my welcome sequence so
it's automated that after they've
received a few emails from me it then
automatically sends them an email that
says hey if you've enjoyed the value
that I've sent you consider giving us a
testimony or consider giving me a
testimonial and that way I collect
testimonials on demand status tip number
four is
luxury looks okay I gave you the Rolex
example in the beginning but that's a
very real example because when you wear
a nice watch or you wear nice clothes
nice leather boots you wear a clean
simple fitted shirt you're in shape you
clearly work out those things are visual
human signals that tell somebody else
that you take yourself seriously I saw a
YouTube clip one time where some guy
said I dress nice because people will
only respect you as much as you respect
yourself and dressing is a form of
respecting yourself and that commands
more dollars I know this sounds Vain and
some people really want to look over
this but I promise you it's worth your
time yes I know not everybody here is
going to have the money to go buy a
cashme sweater to put a Rolex on their
wrist but dressing cleanly and simply
and luxuriously can also be affordable
back when I wasn't making a ton of money
I bought really nice minimal clothes
from H&M clean simple clothes
muted colors get yourself a nice decent
watch seos are great you could get one
for a couple hundred don't wear an Apple
Watch wear a real watch wear real
glasses wear a nice sweater a nice
jacket all of this really matters
because what you're portraying is hey
I'm good at what I do I make money I'm
currently making money and for whatever
reason humans are attracted to giving
more money to people who are already
making money it establishes a trust
where they say well making this money it
must be because they're good in fact I
already know that some of you follow
gurus not because they're good
copywriters but because it looks like
they make a lot of money that's how
ingrained this is into who we are as
humans moving on to the last status tip
status tip number five is use fat
numbers I mentioned it a little bit
before with the testimonials but the
more that you can use measurable numbers
in your
credibility the higher perceived value
and status you have let me give you some
examples things like if I I said I have
200 testimonials that's a lot of
testimonials I could also say I wrote 10
million words in email copyrighting whoa
that's a lot of words right that's not
the most portrayed status because not
all customers care about that but it's
still something it's still some kind of
credit you could say you made your
clients a million dollar in sales or $10
million in sales that's measurable
that's something they care about other
things like you have 5,000 email subscri
subcribers or you have 10,000 YouTube
followers you've worked with 20 Brands
you've sent a th000 emails for clients
there's a bunch of different ways that
you could do this now yes this takes
some work but the good thing is this is
free you can rack up these numbers for
free right you could go build a YouTube
channel for free you can grow your
Twitter account for free you can write
emails every day to your own audience
for free you can work with a bunch of
local brands for free this is the
easiest and most simple way to increase
your status alongside luxury looks right
you could spend 100 bucks get some
decent outfits between that and putting
in the hard work you've immediately
increased your status with the people
around you and so you could demand to
charge more now that's just five very
simple status tips for you to use the
best thing that you could do is what I
like to call status stacking okay status
stacking is when you take all of these
things and stack them together to create
a cohesive powerful status brand so when
you look at my brand you go to my
website you'll notice that everything is
designed beautifully I'm constantly
showing you my testimonials I constantly
pump out big fat numbers I wear very
nice clothes on my profile picture I
wear them in my YouTube videos I wear
them on my client calls I have
high-profile testimonials low profile
testimonials and I'm constantly name
dropping brand Association of
organizations and companies that I've
personally worked with I have them all
over the place and what this does is
overall it increases your perceived
status and so that's the real difference
between $500 copy and $5,000 copy am I
10 times better the copywriter I was
when I was just charging $500 probably
not but I definitely have 10 times the
status and that's what helps you command
the dollar so I hope this video was
helpful for you and if it was I ask you
would you please hit the like and the
Subscribe button it tells me that you
want more free content just like this
and if you're not already on my email
list go ahead and go to Allen dru.com
hop on my email list and read my daily
email copywriters read by over 2,000
copywriters just like you thank you
again so much for watching the video
leave a comment down below and let me
know what video should I make next I'd
love to know what you want me to make
and how I can help you as a copywriter
suc Ed so I appreciate it thank you so
much and I'll chat with you soon